so you know how both of us are
colorblind i do know how both of us are
colorblind so i thought we could do like
a colorblind game
test thingy but colorblindness for me
was not funny
i don't think it's fun do you want to
hear a story
okay no a sad story i'll tell you a sad
story okay so i didn't know that i was
colorblind and nobody knew i was
colorblind the point is that i was in
kindergarten and my mom came to visit
and i was being punished i was put
behind the piano and i was crying
because everybody else was doing uh
painting and i was behind the piano and
separated from the rest of the class
and my mom came in and said why
why is how howard how much howard at the
time why is howard behind the piano and
they said because he's being a bad boy
we keep telling him to paint the ground
green and the sky blue and he doesn't do
it he won't listen to us i don't think
that people take color blindness
seriously like it's actually a point i
found these glasses online called
enchroma glasses and they're scientific
scientifically proven to help people
with colorblindness actually see color
no yeah really yeah i actually they have
that colorblind test on the end chroma
site and it takes like less than two
minutes like less i think like a minute
or something to do it we should do it to
take the colorblind test okay let me
take the color blank okay okay start the
test so this is what i was talking about
i see two okay i see a two go
i see a three okay
i don't see anything
unsure unsure or nothing nothing
my time limit is reached you are mild
protan what does that mean this type of
red green color blindness oh you are
right the red cones in the eye detect
too much green light and not enough red
light haha you are red green color blind
but they do have a bunch of different
glasses now so that so let me try on a
pair of glasses this is blue this is
purple whoa
i've been cured you've been curious
no but it's actually good i was a
kindergarten teacher for 10 years so i
do recommend that if you have kids
in kindergarten like this was a big
issue for me when i was teaching colors
so it is really good to have these
glasses i look good for kids
not only am i not colorblind anymore and
we don't have any way to prove this but
i think i can also play the piano
you are welcome dad anyways um
i did my whole life
my whole life i couldn't see the sixes
and i couldn't see the fours now you can
match and now i can see all the odd
numbers
it's like when that baby hears the voice
it's howie 15 in case you can't hear
over the screaming and crying and you
need color blind glasses it's halley 15
for 15 off one in chrome
all right
you're wearing a nice colored shirt look
at the balloons and look at the boxes
[Music]